and well well well
all too soon
the minister and i find ourselves here
once again
rather than dealing with the cost of
living crisis impacting on families
we're talking
we're talking about scandals in downing
street again and the members opposite
concerned from their positions but
they're allowing this to happen mr
speaker
two months now cabinet ministers have
been working hard to make sue grey the
most famous woman in britain
in response to every question asked
about the poor conduct bad behaviour and
rule breaking culture that this
government has overseen the ministers
have repeatedly told us sue gray is the
answer
now there's a police investigation and
the terms of reference for sue gray set
by the prime minister himself are clear
if any evidence emerges of behavior that
is potentially a criminal offence the
matter will be referred to the police
so it seems mr speaker potential
criminality has been found in downing
street
what a truly damning reflection on our
nation's very highest office
so i ask the minister
given this morning's announcement
when will the su-gray report finally be
published
can he assure the house that the su grey
report will be published in full not
just
the summary and will the accompanying
evidence be provided and can he clarify
for the house what sue grey and her team
will be doing whilst the police conduct
their investigation
can the minister
can confirm whether the decision to
delay the publication of the sugree
report was made by the metropolitan
police or the government
given this government's record mr
speaker on lost phones missing messages
and minutes
can he assure the house that all
evidence from the great inquiry will be
properly held by the cabinet office
can he clarify
if the chancellor as a resident of
downing street is cooperating fully with
the grey inquiry and if the police
investigation and has he been
interviewed
just weeks ago mr speaker the prime
minister told this house there was no
party
how does the pay master general explain
that
i know across the country people know
enough they have made up their minds
about the prime minister so when will
his party catch up
[Applause]